viel gestritten wird gerade auch über
das Bürgergeld und das ist mein Thema
heute Abend in ab dem 1 Januar möchte
die Ampelkoalition die noch aus der
Agenda 2010 stammende Grundsicherung
Hartz IV ersetzen doch es gibt viele
Kritiker die Union kritisiert
beispielsweise die geplante zweijährige
Karenzzeit für die Prüfung von Wohnen
und Vermögen in dieser Zeit würde nach
den Plänen der Ampel der Staat heiz- und
etwaige Mietkosten ohne zu prüfen ob der
leistungsbezirk eine angemessene Wohnung
lebt übernehmen auch spielt die Höhe
eines möglicherweise vorhandenen
Vermögens keine rolle ich frage mich da
schon ob das die richtigen Signale sind
denn während sich laut einem heutigen
weltbericht für die Mittelschicht
Mehrarbeit kaum noch lohnt könnte das
ein falsches Signal sein der Grund warum
es sich nicht lohnt die steuerbelastungs
laut dem Ifo-Institut für viele
Einkommensgruppen ohne Leistungsanreize
ich sehe persönlich nicht erst seit der
corona-pandemie ein beunruhigendes
Bedürfnis der Bundesregierung Menschen
zu finanzieren anstelle von der
Abhängigkeit des Staates benötigen wir
Motivation zur Mehrarbeit die sich
finanziell auch lohnt aber hier würde
ich die Frage die Runde Stellen Herr
Friedrich macht ist der Staat
Arbeitslosen zu leicht absolut und vor
allem bringt immer mehr Menschen in die
Abhängigkeit vom Staat natürlich
Menschen die abhängig sind die gehen
nicht auf die Straße die gehen nicht
protestieren die werden nicht
unzufrieden aber beißt nie in die Hand
die einen selber füttert und natürlich
ist es wenig Anreize noch was zu
verdienen immer mehr Mittelständler
sagen weil bei uns überhaupt noch
arbeiten gehen ich habe rekordabgaben
und es sind 200 Euro mehr die ich
lediglich habe dann bleibe ich doch
lieber zu Hause liegt die Füße auf den
Tischen schauen bisschen Bild TV
eine ganz tolle Idee sie würden also
Finanzminister Christian Lindner
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck und
Kanzler Olaf Scholz unterstellen dass
sie Menschen abhängig machen wollen um
sie gefügig zu machen Sozialismus ist ja
wieder die Lösung bei allem wir sind
noch immer mehr Umverteilung was die
meisten Deutschen nicht wissen linke
Tasche ist rechte Tasche das heißt wenn
der Staat Geld verschenkt muss das ja
irgendwo anders herbekommen und wir sind
der Staat das heißt entweder über
Steuererhöhungen oder zwei Schulden für
die wir jeweils haften oder halt zahlen
und es begreifen die meisten nicht und
aus diesem Grund ist es natürlich eine
Art abhängigmachung der Menschen von der
Politik damit die nicht unzufrieden sind
dass die Politik sich aufspielen kann
und sagen kann wir haben die Krise
gelöst wir geben euch doch ein bisschen
was gern Geld ein kleines zögerchen
damit ihr Ruhe gibt brot und Spiele all
over again Herr patzell würden sie damit
gehen ist der Staat doch kein
Weihnachtsmann mit Rauschebart sondern
eigentlich sind die Geschenke eher süßes
Gift jene die den Staat leiten nehmen
gerne die Rolle des Weihnachtsmannes an
und hoffen dass dann die kleinen Kinder
auch jauchzen vor Freude über die
schönen Geschenke ich glaube freilich
nicht das so böse Absichten wir wollen
die Leute abhängig machen dahinter
stehen es ist einfach der in Deutschland
auf den Wiederaufbau nach dem
30-jährigen Krieg Zurückgehen der Glaube
dass der Staat die Verpflichtung hat als
wohlmeinender Vater um die im Grunde ja
unmündigen unselbständigen Bürger sich
zu kümmern das ist der grundreflex und
der ist naturgemäß bei die
Sozialdemokraten wesentlich stärker
ausgeprägt als bei Liberalen und da sind
sich dann die großen Parteien von der
CDU bis zu den Grünen und
Sozialdemokraten von der Linken gar
nicht lang zu reden einig dass der Staat
ein aktivierender Start sein muss denn
der Bürger ohne dass der Staat in
fördert fordert oder belohnt würde ja
gar nicht aktiv und diese grundlegende
aktive Stadt gegen das Bürgergeld also
CDU kämpft gerade sehr stark dann Gott
sei Dank sie ist aufgewacht und begreift
dass es hier ein systematisches Problem
gibt wenn die Abstände zwischen dem was
ich durch Arbeit erreiche und dem was
ich bekomme wenn ich mich vom Staat
betiteln lasse zu gering sind dann wird
natürlich ein neues Jobwunder nicht
stattfinden können jetzt schon sind bei
vielen Leuten die reden zu hören ich
will eine Work-Life-Balance ich will ja
gar nicht voll arbeiten mir lang dein
halber Job ich brauche ja auch meine
Zeit um mich zu erholen an dieser Stelle
braucht es tatsächlich eine
Mentalitätswandel und den wird
eigentlich nur eine sich verschärfende
not die dann auch den einzelnen so weit
betrifft dass der Staat in nicht mehr
vor den fairnissen des Lebens bewahren
kann trifft zu diesem Mentalität nicht
die richtige Motivation um das einmal
zusammenzubringen
Motivation sagen viele manch andere
sagen nein es sei ganz im Gegenteil ein
Bürger der nicht arbeiten muss der
stellt eben deswegen seine Arbeitskraft
der Gesellschaft zur Verfügung der
Gesellschaft ging es viel besser müssen
die Leute nicht zu früh aufstehen und
kämen dann ausgepowert nach Hause und
das ist dann eben sozusagen der
Unterschied in den Daten auf die man
sich bezieht und es ist der Unterschied
in der ideologischen Grundhaltung glaube
ich sozusagen dass der Mensch edle
hilfreich und gut ist oder glaube ich
dass er sich nur dann so richtig
anstrengt wenn es tatsächlich den Zwang
gibt sich anzustängen gehen wir einmal
in die Details des Bürgergeldes rein ich
habe ja eben schon dieses Sonderform
also Schonvermögen angesprochen das
würde 60.000 Euro betragen und Christian
Lindner sagt zum Beispiel man sollte
leider nicht zu sehr debattieren um
nicht in einen schäbigkeitswettbewerb
hereinzukommen da würde ich gerne
Sebastian Geister aus unserer
Politikredaktion fragen wie du das
siehst was das schon Vermögen das
Sondervermögen betrifft was die ersten
zwei Jahre nicht angegriffen wird also
mir macht das ehrlicherweise ein
bisschen fassungslos ist genau wie du
gesagt hast es sind 60.000 Euro für den
ersten Leistungsbezieher und dann für
die Bedarfsgemeinschaft ist es so da
kommen dann noch ich glaube es sind
30.000 Euro pro Person dazu
150.000 Euro die vom Staat sozusagen
also die nicht angetastet werden müssen
die ich nicht selbst verbrauchen muss
und der Staat zahlt mir trotzdem schon
Geld Geld das erarbeitet werden muss von
uns allen vom Steuerzahler das macht
mich fassungslos wie man überhaupt auf
die Idee kommen kann das ja so viel zu
hoch angesetzt das sollte es wohl nicht
sein
hier ist natürlich jetzt die Frage dass
meinte christelinda mit diesem
schäbigkeitswettbewerb wenn jemand
Schicksalsschlag hat da reinfällt ob es
nicht fairer wäre dieses Schonvermögen
erstmal zu behalten aber nicht in dieser
Höhe also bin ich 150.000 Euro auf der
hohen Kante habe vielleicht ein Haus
besitze vielleicht mehrere Autos noch
dann finde ich es zumutbar dass das
angetastet wird zumindest das
Barvermögen das schon wir sprechen jetzt
ja gar nicht darüber also das jetzt die
Regelsätze angehoben werden wie sehr die
Hartz IV Regelsätze bislang sind wenn da
50 € drauf kommt Inflationsausgleich das
kann man ja machen das ja auch richtig
da geht im übrigen auch die Union mit da
ging wohl auch die FDP mit das kann man
machen aber 150.000 € schon Vermögen das
ist unmittelbar glaube ich auch kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen dass das so
durchgeht damit der Bundesrat ob das
dann durchgeht wie stehen sie zum
Bürgergeld ich halte es auch für
hochproblematisch genau aus dem Punkt
wir können ja überhaupt nicht berechnen
was da fair wäre sind wir bei dem Punkt
was das zumutbar was es nicht zumutbar
ähnliche Diskussion führen wir jetzt
gerade Richtung bedarfsorientierte
energiepreisbremse wir haben überhaupt
nicht die Daten um zu Mitteln was
ermitteln was soll überhaupt auf der
Bedarf sein macht es einen Unterschied
ob sich jemand darum kümmert dass sein
günstigen Energieversorger hat und da
vielleicht wirklich auch tagelang
wochenlang im Internet sucht und
versucht sich da auch selber auch und
und Energie zu sparen oder sagt man
einfach eine mega der Start wird schon
übernehmen
ich habe eine eine spannende Zahl noch
die hat Jens teutrine von der FDP ganz
stark beworben und zwar die
Hinzuverdienst Regeln für Jugendliche um
mal vielleicht ein positiven Fakt beim
Bürgergeld zu finden und zwar bislang
ist es so Hartz IV bestraft aktuell
Jugendliche also sie dürfen von dem 450
Euro Job nur 170 Euro behalten wenn die
Eltern Hartz 4 Empfänger sind ist das
für Sie Herr Friedrich der richtige
Schritt in die richtige Richtung dass
die Jugendlichen hinzuverdienen dürfen
egal wie ob die Eltern Hartz 4 haben
oder nicht absolut also generell sollte
Arbeit sich wieder lohnen dass man
einfach sagt höhere Freibeträge nicht
nur für die Jugendlichen für die Kinder
von Hartz IV Empfängern sind auch für
die Hartz IV Empfänger an sich selbst
dass sie wieder in den Arbeitsprozess in
die Arbeitswelt reinkommen Steuern
zahlen man nur durch steuerein solche
Sachen wieder leisten aber ich glaube
tatsächlich dass es hier auch um eine
Art wählergeschenk ist dass man einfach
versucht ein Kreuzchen zu ergattern für
die nächste Wahl und dahingehend sehen
wir diese Umverteilung damit der die
breite Masse wohlgesonnen ist den
Parteien geht es dann verabschieden und
deswegen bin ich ganz stark dagegen ist
es der falsche Ansatz und es wird
wahrscheinlich mehr Geld kosten mehr
Probleme eruieren weil wir brauchen ja
eigentlich die arbeitende Bevölkerung
wir haben ein demografisches Problem wir
brauchen nicht weniger Kräfte wir
brauchen Fachkräfte überall den Menschen
die Firmen suchen händeringend nach
Arbeitnehmern und finden keine und dann
erzähl noch so die Leute zu verleiten zu
sagen kommt bleibt zu Hause ist lohnt
sich sowas nicht zu arbeiten das ist der
falsche Ansatz absolut das ist genau das
Problem ich glaube übrigens auch nicht
da bin ich bei einem Patzelt ich glaube
nicht dass der Mensch zur Arbeit
gezwungen werden muss oder wenn ich es
natürlich rational mache dass man sagt
ich bleibe lieber zu Hause weil ich
nämlich als vierköpfige Familie am Ende
dann 3000 noch was Euro im Monat bekomme
die Miete wird ja auch übernommen dann
ist es eben rational eigentlich zu sagen
ich gehe eigentlich zur Arbeit ich
kriege ja sogar mehr Geld wenn ich zu
Hause bleibe das kann der Staat
eigentlich nicht ernsthaft ermöglichen
Kompass aber Herr Patzelt warum fällt es
denn im Staat so schwer dieses fordern
und fördern durchzusetzen also Hartz IV
ist ja auch nicht das richtige System um
jetzt Menschen zu fördern das würde ich
jetzt zum Beispiel nicht sagen das
Bürgergeld scheint jetzt auch wieder
seine Tücken zu haben warum ist es denn
so schwierig vielleicht nicht einfach
die Steuerlast etwas runter zu nehmen
der Staat ist der dabei immer größere
sogenannte Sondervermögen aufzulegen
also Verschuldungen auf sich zu nehmen
und wird allmählich an die Grenzen
seiner finanziellen Möglichkeiten
getrieben da liegt es natürlich nahe wie
auch jetzt die Debatte ist dass man eben
die Steuern erhöht und um sozusagen bei
nicht allzu vielen Wählern hier Missmut
zu erzeugen sagten es wäre nur die
besser verdienenden besteuert die aber
ohnehin schon an großen Teil und
verstanden haben zwei der Steuerzahler
also wissen Sie eigentlich viel zu
Weltmeister am Steuer zahlen ja und wir
wollen immer Weltmeister werden
immer höher und Stärke beim Fußball wäre
es besser wenn man Weltmeister aber auch
das ist wahrscheinlich nicht in
Reichweite ich glaube das wesentliche
Problem ist die Demokratie also
Demokratie ist nichts falsch aber sie
setzt für Politiker folgenden Anreiz
wenn ich in den Wahlkampf gehe was Gott
lob alle vier Jahre der Fall ist wenn
ich den Wahlkampf gehe muss ich den
Leuten klar machen können was ich für
sie getan habe und am klarsten ist so
etwas klar zu machen wenn ich sage du
bist jetzt in der Hinsicht besser
gestellt dort haben wir die Wohltat
verteilt dort haben wir jenes getan wir
haben die Lebensumstände verbessert
ein Politiker der hintritt und sagt wir
müssen jetzt erst einmal die
Staatsausgaben kürzen und du wirst es
auch fühlen denn manche Unterstützung
für dich wird entfallen der wird sich
schwer tun im Wald haben wir es einmal
ganz konkret machen mit welchen drei
Punkten könnte man Hartz IV oder wenn
man es dann das Bürgergeld nennen wollen
würde reformieren ich glaube das ist gar
nicht mehr reformierbar man muss es
entweder in der Klarheit lassen in der
Bundeskanzler Schröder ist eingeführt
hat fordern und fördern so dass es auch
wirklich persönlich ein Unterschied
macht ob ich zur Arbeit gehe oder nicht
oder man löst das ganze auf früher
hatten wir ja den stigmatisierenden
Effekt dass das was später Hartz IV ist
Sozialhilfe ist da wollte ja schon
eigentlich niemand sich hier
stigmatisieren lassen aus der
Sozialhilfe wird jetzt über Hartz IV des
Bürgergeld und am Schluss merkt man der
richtig gute Bürger ist der der mit
Dankbarkeit vom Staat das Geld nimmt und
dann nicht aufmuckt noch einmal ich
glaube nicht dass das sozusagen eine
finstere Absicht dahinter ist aber es
ist natürlich eine Freude
ist dazu noch derjenige der das vom
Staat nimmt was im Politiker vorsagen so
musst du denken dass es richtig ich
erkläre es dir denn dass es Wissenschaft
das ist jetzt der allgemeine
bei euch noch aber noch einmal ein sehr
Friedrich die Frage ob sie dann drei
Punkte haben also ich gebe schon mal ein
ich finde es gut dass zum Beispiel bei
den Jugendlichen die Sätze erhöht werden
also sie auch die kompletten 450 Euro
behalten dürfen und nicht mehr nur noch
170 Euro haben sie einen konkreten Punkt
mehr als 4 den sie verändern würden ja
ich würde Hartz 4 tatsächlich abschaffen
ich glaube der nächste Schritt die
nächste Stufe wird nun ab
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen sein die
dann das Staat verteilen wird an alle
Bedürftigen die wirklich bedürftig
Bedürfnisse haben und Geld brauchen aber
man kann Hartz IV nicht mehr reformieren
dass es durch dessen sich alle Experten
einig das Bürgergeld ist leider eine
Verschlimmbesserung wiederum wird sehr
sehr viel Geld kosten bürokratische
Aufwand ohne Ende und auch im Endeffekt
wieder scheitern in wenigen Jahren
werden wir hier sitzen genau darüber
damit er sprechen dass es ebenfalls
geschadet ist genauso wie Hartz IV